Letterman did you did you do well on
Letterman or were you upset by it no so
interesting so with Letterman you know I
was of course very nervous whatever and
the other guest was John Travolta so
Travolta's on killing being
Travolta and then there's a 90c
commercial break where Travolta is
walking out past me and I'm standing
right there and I was of course not
going to say anything and he just stops
and he looks at me he goes what a
beautiful suit you have on I was like
thanks I feel like it's a little big he
was like it's beautiful I was like thank
you and he goes what do you do and I was
like oh I do um I do comedy he was like
great that's amazing he was like and um
are you on the show I was like yeah it's
my first time ever uh actually on TV he
was like great he goes you've done it
already then I said no this is my first
time I haven't done it yet he goes no
it's over and I said no no John I'm
going on next and he was like no you've
done it you have to understand the mo
you've done all the work you've he's
like I'm sure Mr Mr Letterman had to vet
you I'm sure you've practiced this set a
100 times it's over now you just have to
go live the moment this is the fun part
there is zero pressure now you've done
it it it's over and then he put his hand
on my heart just right away and he goes
oh my God your heart is beating so fast
I said well you know you're John chol
you have your hand on my nipple so it's
it's nerve-wracking and he was like calm
down you've done it remember this is
over you've done it it's over and and
and he said to me and on the chest he
goes I'm going to watch you live this
moment this is cool I'm going to watch
you live this moment now go make this
the easiest five minutes you've ever
done because the hard work is over and
with that the producer puts his hand on
my shoulder I go out so he releases his
hand Travolta releas his hand I walk out
I had what I think is one of the calest
best sets I've had still to this date in
my career the only thing I could feel is
my kneecap shaking a little bit because
you know that Energy's got to go
somewhere but I nailed it I I felt I
could the crowd was great you know David
letman shook my hand whispered he was
like that was great and and I felt so
good and I'm walking off and I see my
mother you know right there she's like
that was amazing oh I'm like thank you
and then I said where's John Travolta
and they said he left immediately just
right away he's he just he had a you
know he's flying to Zimbabwe whatever he
flies on PL he's out of here so they
said you know but I but I don't I never
found I never was upset by that cuz I'm
like he did everything he could to calm
me down and he was like my work is done
I'm not going to see watch this
do 5 minutes with I'm John Chola and you
know he's right you've done all your
prep work you're that's it and then the
thing is too like with just being a
standup comic is where you know we're
massachus in a way so I felt great I it
was amaz I just felt awesome my family
was there my mom and dad were there my
stepmom was there all the people I
needed to be we there it just felt
awesome and I'm like you know what I
feel so good right now that I need to
ruin this
immediately and I need to go downtown to
this place called the Village Lantern on
bleer street where we all do open mics
and these shows and I said I need to do
the same exact set that I just felt so
good with I need to do it from f for
five people from Sweden that don't speak
English and just bomb with this set in
the suit and why because why did you
need to do that it just I wouldn't do
that necessarily today but back then at
that time I was like it it all you feel
fraudulent I think because there is no
route to becoming a comedian there's no
objective measure it's all subjec of how
people feel so you feel a bit fraudulent
of why am I actually how did I actually
get that show so I went down and I
bombed with this set and I was with my
you uh she ex-girlfriend now but
girlfriend at the time and we're coming
out of the village uh underground and
you know just going to go get a bite or
something like that and Tracy Morgan is
just walking by and I was like what the
hell tra this what a night and then you
know I don't know him but my girlfriend
at the time she was like oh Tracy she
was like Tracy Morgan and he was like
what's up baby girl you look good with
your toes painted like Skittles he was
like I like that he was like y he was
like you got colorful feet and I was
like yeah yeah she does and then she
goes oh this is my boyfriend Chris she
goes he just did David Letterman and
then he looks at me and he goes I always
knew you had it in you I
always knew you was that dude and I said
Tracy we never met he goes I'm tell you
bro I'm proud of you man I'm proud of
you and I and he starts getting like
emotional I said Tracy I appreciate all
this but I think you might be confusing
me you never met he goes you're the
man dude never forget that
you're the man and then he and he had no
shirt on and he was wearing this big
chain and he was like just never forget
bro that you the man he goes I love
David Letterman man he loves you too and
I was like thank
you